bonjour et bienvenue dans ce set up
science consacrée aujourd'hui à
l'origine de la paléontologie et souvent
vendue comme étant la science des
origines celles censées répondre à la
question d'où venons nous pourtant aussi
curieux que cela puisse paraître il n'y
a pas plus mal placé qu'un
paléontologues pour répondre à cette
question puisque d'après les données les
plus récentes la vie serait apparu il ya
plus de 4 milliards d'années et que de
cette époque là aucun fossile ne nous
est parvenu en bas un sens n'est ce pas
mais ne cédons pas à la panique et à
chante plutôt de définir ce que l'on
cherche avec précision pour chercher
l'origine de la vie il faut d'abord
définir avec précision ce qu'est la vie
et bien c'est simple la vie c'est
l'activité chercher l'origine de la vie
c'est chercher le moment où les choses
se sont animées se sont détachés de la
matière inerte
la vie c'est ce souffle cette énergie
aux eaux calmes ses envolées lyriques
pardon c'est l'appel de la poésie oui
c'est ça oui et puis si la vie ce
n'était qu'une histoire d'énergie ou de
matières animé que l'on oppose à de la
matière inerte
alors le soleil dont le coeur brûle
d'une perpétuelle réaction nucléaire
devrait être aussi considéré comme un
être vivant
bon rien tout nouveau quelque chose de
plus terre à terre
cliniquement parlant la vie c'est quoi
un être humain est déclaré mort quand
son cerveau et son coeur cesse de
fonctionner mais il est impossible
d'étendre cette définition aux arbres et
aux micro organismes qui peuplent notre
planète
ces microbes n'ont vraiment pas de coeur
bon arrêtons de taper au hasard et
visons juste ce qu'il nous faut c'est
une caractéristique de la vie qui soit
d'une part commune a absolument tous les
êtres vivants et d'autre part qu'ils ne
s'en présente qui exclusivement chez les
êtres vivants
on appelle ce type de caractéristiques
une homologie selon une définition qui
fut donné par le terrifiant
redoutable le bruyant et charden bien
sûr concrètement une homologie qu'est ce
que c'est prenons un exemple nous avons
tous comme nos amis les chats et les
grenouilles une tête une paire de bras
et une paire de jambes
or de telles ressemblance n'aurait aucun
sens si nous considérions que chacun de
ces animaux étaient apparus
indépendamment et oui dans ce cas
pourquoi ce ressemblerait-il autant pour
restaurer semblerait-il tout court alors
que tant des extravagances sont
possibles la seule réponse sensée et
qu'ils doivent descendre tous da même
ancêtre commun
muni lui aussi deux bras deux jambes et
d'une tête et dont ils ont hérité ce
plan d'organisation fondamental que
n'ont pas les boules paix des prêts sont
par exemple la tête les bras et les
jambes des hommes des chats et des
grenouilles ont donc été héritée d'un
ancêtre qui leur est commun ce sont des
homologie reste donc à trouver des
caractéristiques qui soit homologue à la
vie tout entière des mammifères aux
amphibiens en passant par les végétaux
et les bactéries ou encore les
champignons alors on donne sa langue au
chat
pas de panique réfléchir plus tôt
sans trop se faire de mal on peut déjà
dire que nous possédons tous des
cellules qui nous constitue oui enfin
contrairement à microbes je suis quand
même fait un peu plus que d'une seule
cellule quand même à aujourd'hui oui
mais rappelle toi ya très longtemps et
aussi qu'ils n'étaient qu'une cellule à
d'accord j'ai compris l'idée la vie a dû
commencer par des êtres vivants à une
seule cellule
quoi d'autre eh bien nous autres êtres
vivants sommes les seules entités à
pouvoir nous reproduire et ce quel que
soit notre taille ou le nombre de nos
cellules
cette propriété unique est due à la
présence d' adn à l'intérieur de nos
cellules en effet l'adn et les autres
des acides nucléiques comme la rn sont
les seuls molécules ayant comme
propriété de faire des copies
d'elle-même il n'y en a pas d'autre et
en tant que grande maison à adn c'est à
nous que celui ci a confié la lourde
tâche de nous reproduire afin que ces
copies continue d'exister dans le temps
et se répandent quelle qu'en soit la
difficulté
heureusement nous et la plupart des
animaux sommes capables et de telle
façon que cela reste plus un plaisir
qu'une corvée sinon qu'ils
s'entendraient la peine
la capacité de reproduction est un trait
fondamental de la vie que nous avons
hérité de la toute première molécule
capable de s'auto dupliquer et c'est
important car sans cette capacité à se
copier il n'y a pas d'évolution possible
en effet la molécule d'adé n est
constituée de molécules
encore plus petite les fameux à tcg lors
d'une copie d'une génération à une autre
une erreur d'écriture peut avoir lieu
c'est ce qu'on appelle une mutation et
comme l'adn et en quelques sortes le
manuel permettant la construction
l'utilisation et l'entretien d'un
organisme vivant de petites mutations
sur des fragments important d'adr nommer
les gènes peuvent avoir des effets
incroyable par exemple les mutants du
gène sonic hedgehog
et non ce n'est pas un gag c'est le vrai
nom qu'on a donné à ce gène peuvent
avoir des mains et des pieds et parfois
même le visage très très déformée chez
les plantes les mutants du gène superman
est toujours servir aux montres de
sérieuse anomalie de la fleur donc une
simple toute petite mutation de rien du
tout et elles ne sont pas si rares peut
avoir de grands effets sur un organisme
mais heureusement il existe des
mécanismes de régulation
déjà il existe toute une machinerie
cellulaire permettant de détecter les
mutations et de les réparer ensuite
toutes les mutations ne vont pas avoir
des effets désastreux
certaines n'auront aucun effet et
d'autre que de très faibles
par exemple prenons le gène des yeux
bleus et se gênent n'existe pas et n'ont
imaginé qu'une mutations surviennent sur
un tel gène et vous vous retrouveriez
avec des yeux verts but au rouge vif
voire pas du tout en fait il n'existe
pas un mais plusieurs gènes impliqués
dans la couleur des yeux ici même plus
grave que ça la plupart des gènes
fonctionnent en réseau interconnecté et
jouant des rôles plus ou moins
importants pour d'autres organes divers
et variés du coup quand l'un de ces
gènes mute loin de faire s'effondrer
tout processus cette mutation peut fort
bien passée quasi inaperçue et non
désolé spy dit ce sera pour une autre
fois
donc finalement tout est sorti cette
capacité de reproduction répondre à
cette question en revient à s'en poser
une autre
d'où vient la vie les êtres vivants sont
comme des constructions fait de briques
de base pour l'adn et les autres acides
nucléiques comme la rn ses briques de
base sont des molécules représenté par
les fameuses lettres à tc et j'ai pour
les protéines c'est ce qu'on appelle les
acides aminés et qu'ils la trouveront
cette blague et oui toutes ces briques
de base sont faites à partir des mêmes
constituants fondamentaux encore plus
petit des atomes les plus importants
sont les atomes de carbone bien sûr des
atomes d'azoté et des atomes d'hydrogène
le tout baignant dans de l'eau
on trouve ces composants en grande
quantité sur terre le carbone est
présent dans l'air sous forme de notre
dioxyde de carbone le fameux co2 la zone
constitue quant à lui plus de 70 % de
notre atmosphère
enfin l'hydrogène et bien c'est tout
simplement le hb dans la formule de
l'eau h2o donc notre terre ne ment pas
de ses composants nécessaires à la
formation du vivant et on sait qu'ils
étaient déjà présents il ya 4 milliards
d'années sur la terre primitive
ils sont aussi présents en bonne
quantité dans les comètes et les
nébuleuses
donc si tous les ingrédients pour
fabriquer des acides aminés et des bases
azotées sont présents partout dans
l'univers ont-ils pu spontanément
s'assembler il ya 4 milliards d'années
pour former la vie la réponse est oui
car les briques de base de la vie semble
pour mars assemblée dans tous les
milieux
même les plus difficiles et ce de façon
spontanée on a depuis longtemps
retrouver des acides aminés et même des
protéines sur des météorites qui ont
résister malgré la chaleur due à la
traversée de l'atmosphère et des atomes
semble même capable de s'assembler en
acides aminés dans les nippes u2
protosolaire sous l'action des uv mais
cela ne veut pas forcément dire pour
autant que la vie est apparue dans
l'espace cela nous montre simplement que
la formation des constituants de la vie
cpq tout seul
naturellement même dans les conditions
très difficiles du vide spatial
d'ailleurs des expériences de
reconstitution de l'atmosphère de la
terre primitive mené depuis les années
et encore aujourd'hui montre que comme
dans le vide spatial les consultants de
la vie peuvent se combiner de même sur
terre aussi et ce malgré les
bombardement météoritique les volcans
les orages et autres cataclysmes qui
ravageait la terre à l'époque c'est peut
être même un peu grâce à énergie
considérable apportée par ces
cataclysmes que les atomes est
essentielle à la vie on puisse se
combiner il semble que l'argile est plus
aussi aidé à l'apparition de la vie
car il est constitué de masse feuillet
qui purent servir d'échafaudages à la
construction des premières molécules
replica trice l'ancêtre de l'adn à c'est
pour ça qu'on était aussi content de
trouver de l'argent sur mars
c'est parce qu'en présence d'argile
d'eau et d'une atmosphère l'apparition
de la vie devient nettement plus facile
ben si il est si facile de recréer
briques de base de la vie pourquoi
n'attend toujours pas réussi à recréer
la vie en laboratoire la réponse est
très simple nous manquons de temps la
terre s'est formé il ya quatre milliards
et demi d'années la vie est apparue au
plus tôt il ya 4 milliards d'années ce
qui représente un laps de temps de pas
moins de 500 millions d'années pour
permettre à la bonne conjoncture
d'événements nécessaires à l'apparition
de la vie de se produire on dit souvent
qu en géologie on n'est pas aux millions
d'années près mais là pour vous donner
une idée il y à 500 millions d'années
notre plus proche parent fossiles
ressembler à ça c'est vous dire
l'importance considérable de ce pas de
temps finalement quel qu'ait pu être
l'ancêtre de l'adn sur terre celui ci
devait être une molécule beaucoup plus
simple dans sa constitution et surtout
avoir la capacité de faire des copies de
lui même c'est à dire de se reproduire
car c'est à cette seule condition que
des mutations au pu apparaître lors
d'erreurs de copies ayant petit à petit
par sélection naturelle permis
l'apparition de l'adn tel qu'on le
connaît aujourd'hui
cette science est terminé merci de
l'avoir suivi nous espérons vous avoir
convaincus que la vie a pu émerger sur
terre spontanément à partir d'atomes
simple mais abondant et que si vous êtes
né d'une cellule unique en à peine neuf
mois 4 milliards d'années ont été
largement suffisant pour que l'action
conjuguée des mutations et de la
sélection naturelle fasse apparaître et
évoluer la vie telle que nous la
connaissons aujourd'hui
pour en savoir plus nous vous
conseillons la lecture des chapitres
consacrés à l'origine de la vie dans les
ouvrages suivants ainsi que la lecture
du soleil la terre et la vie écrit par
les spécialistes français en la matière
merci à tous